now to present the award of the best
actress here is a gentleman who won the
Oscar last year for his performance as
Elmer Gantry he is so imbued with the
spirit of the park it took the studio
six weeks to get him out of the choir
loft here is mr. Burt Lancaster
bird do you want me to stick around and
help you tear open the envelope you
could slit it open that's not having a
nose jokes this far down in the show
having suffered a similar Audio five
talented ladies are going through at
this very moment and I'll get right to
the point
nominated for Best Performance by an
actress
our Audrey Hepburn in Breakfast at
Tiffany's Piper Laurie in the husk and
Geraldine pays in summer and smoke
Natalie Wood in Splenda in the grass
Sophia Loren
so fail are into women I was saving it
the winner is Sophia law
this gossin will accept from us Lauren
who cannot be answered oh it's such an
exciting moment I'm honored to accept
this for Miss Sophia Lauren and I wish
so very much she could be with us
tonight so all of us here and our great
television audience could share this
exciting moment with this wildly
beautiful and talented girl
congratulations Sophia wherever you are
and we do so earnestly wish you good
health and happiness along with this
wonderful award